Psychologists use research methods just like biologists and chemists do. The
only difference is, our questions are about thought and behavior, and their
questions are about things like plants or chemicals. This lesson is really
important, because research methods gives us a foundation for the rest of the
course. because after all, without research, we wouldn't be able to learn
anything new. In this lesson you are going to learn the skills necessary to
become a better critical consumer research. Every day in the news there are
stories popping up about topics related to psychology. Let's take a look at
this one. Here we see that those who media multitask are 70% more likely to
experience symptoms of anxiety and depression. Now, can we say that media
multitasking causes symptoms of anxiety and depression? No, we cannot. And we
can't because this is an example of a correlational study. In this lesson we'll
see that the type of research design, dictates whether or not we can say a
causal statement. Or whether or not we can say two variables are just related.